he's the country singer from Mississippi
lives in Nashville now his bio states
the following an orphan who turned into
a preacher preacher turned into a
songwriter songwriter who turned into a
drunk and a drunk that is learning to be
a human being that's a full life there
Travis thanks for joining us good to be
here it was I'm scrambling my phone
started but I went up a friend of mine
drew Kennedy who's a artist in Texas
said oh you're on the Dan Patrick story
like trying to wake up anyway so I guess
you could add a human trying to wake up
to the conversation now I was playing I
was listening to underdog and and the
person who turned me on to you was Jake
oh and I said I saw Jake at Pebble Beach
and he was talking about he won know
what kind of music I listened to and and
I said you know I'm listening everything
I've been getting into a country a lot
more and he goes I got somebody for you
and he mentioned you I get back home I
go to Spotify and all of a sudden I see
the songs that are you know the most
played and then I stumble upon underdog
and I'm thinking oh boy that that's a
theme song the Philadelphia Eagles were
they played up that they were underdogs
this year they wore the dog masks during
the playoffs they won the Super Bowl and
I thought that is a perfect song for the
Philadelphia Eagles I don't know if
you're an underdog fan and that's why
you wrote it who did you write that
about or what did you write that about
well I wrote it you know I've kind of
always considered myself an underdog you
know because one of those that you know
the least expected to succeed you know
yeah and ironically I do I'm not a huge
sports fan I hate to admit that on your
show but but I do watch the Super Bowl
every year and the commentators
inevitably will get around to call them
somebody an underdog and that's who I
know who I'm pulling for so this year
was pretty spectacular with the Eagles
and the Patriots you know and and then I
found out about them you know referring
to themselves is $100 yeah ever so I
happen to agree with you I think that
would be a great song for the for the
Eagles so you're open to the idea of me
loaning this song to the Eagles so they
can play it in the arena you
in the stadium I think that'd be awesome
are you a football fan only for the
Superbowl but is a big deal yeah yeah
once you have one game a year and that's
the that's the one so did you have a
favorite player growing up well when I
was a kid my grandparents raised me so
so we watched you know we were big Ole
Miss fans and Archie Manning was a big
deal when I was a kid I got that my dad
took me and we stood in line that one of
the few things meeting my dad did
together we went in stood in line and
got an autograph from Archie and then
and I believe he went on to play with
the Saints and yeah I'm almost positive
we went down to New Orleans and it was a
day long playing they wouldn't let me
out because it was so crazy but we went
to see that game and then I distinctly
remember being so tiny and people going
nuts in the hallways knocking on doors
and everything it was pretty exciting
for a lord highroad I was four or five
six years old it was a it was a kind of
a just in my memory how long you been
performing
oh man I you know I've been I've been
tinkering with music my whole life I
started writing poems and and I've been
started playing the drums when I was 10
or 11 and then at 21 I discovered the
singer-songwriters and and there were
some people in Gatlinburg I went up
there I was going to be a bluegrass
musician and be a hillbilly and smoke
weed and then I found out how hard
bluegrass mute it was so I opted out for
smoking weed and and then and then I
found some guys playing acoustic music
for tips and I looked in the door and
there had to be 30 or 40 dollars in
there and I'm thinking man you could
make 30 or 40 dollars a day playing a
guitar so that kind of started the
journey for me trying to figure out how
to you know make me do for a living and
get people to pay attention to me well
you write songs Hank Williams jr. Eric
Church Dierks Bentley you know that's
pretty impressive list there yeah it
it's it's been a real exciting ride
Wynonna Judd recorded one sheep and
she's actually become kind of a
Jayco when you mentioned earlier he has
been so kind to me he recorded that song
and put me on both of his videos and
apparently now he's out there talking me
up you know two to two people as well
he's just he was very kind hearted sign
rod man hearts I leave behind this great
song great it's so well written and
that's the first thing I noticed when I
started listening to your music is what
you were saying and how you were saying
it so I I applaud you like that thank
you so much I don't I don't pull the
little ear pull any punches lyrically I
just oh I know I listen to a nice girl
you have anything to say you know yeah I
listen to nice girl Travis I know you
don't pull any punches
she actually recently died and I wasn't
sure how to feel that that sounds like
the name of a song she recently died and
I don't know how to feel yeah that
Travis I'm going to give that to you
okay and here's the other one I got one
I got it I got a song title for I'm good
at song titles I'm not good at anything
else okay you can't spell blame without
me that's actually pretty good you can
take it you can take it alright you do
all the work
alright I'll do all the work and call
you and tell you alright do get to the
Northeast at all I know you're
performing in Nashville here coming up
in March but do you come up towards New
York Connecticut New Jersey has just has
just worked out some kind of a deal in
New York where they'll because they have
the Bluebird on the mountain and I think
they're doing a stone songwriters
showcase up in New York and I think I'll
be coming up there I don't remember when
but I will be coming up that that way
alright then your people I have to let
my people know because I'd love to be
able to see you in person in say hello I
would love that
now I will make sure that that happens
and I want to let people hear it again
and now once you get to the chorus here
that's where it really sells me you know
there's a little bit of Queen we will
rock you did right
did you factor that in I did I actually
that was kind of an on purpose because
you know you mentioned some of our
earlier records my earlier records my
first record was me getting out of rehab
and documenting it because I was just in
a real bad place and so one of my
counselors suggested that I make a
record that I keep a journal and I made
a record instead and so that so all of
these songs started off kind of a dark
you know man digging out of a whole kind
of music and and I've grown as a human
and and those struggles are not as big
as they used to be and so I'm basically
I'm happier and I thought my fans have
been sitting here listening you know for
years now to these depressing songs I
need to make some more uplifting so they
don't want to slip through it my shows
anymore so so that's that was an on
purpose I purposely put some some
happier things on this record so so you
know to give people some some time to
catch their breath in between these
other songs
well did you write about it it gets
better where you're talking about what
to do in your downtime instead of
drinking or doing drugs is it gets
better it gets better was actually me
trying not to drink that was I wrote
that song literally because I was
driving the tube to some recovery type
meetings and I had to pass the bars that
I used to go to and I used to pass the
liquor store that I went to and and so
that whole thing about if I can just get
inside my door not you know and lock it
and try again to you know tomorrow that
was yes that was it that was a rough
time man and his killing uncle buzzy is
that killing the buzz that was my aunt
that was my alter ego it was he was
really fun for about the first 10
minutes man and then he you know he
wasn't fun anymore he wound up getting
neck and going to jail and he's just
just wasn't fun anymore
waitwait getting naked going to jail is
another song title man I'm just full of
them there's no I should I should get up
this early everything I'm sure in your
dark days you didn't get up this early
you were just going to bed probably oh
yeah no uncle buzzy all right I want
people to listen to it I even if you're
and I hate Santa but even if you're not
a country fan you'll just love what is
said here and how it's said in the music
and something different for Travis
Meadows it's it's something upbeat it's
called we are the underdogs and Travis
thanks for joining us we'll play the
song and hopefully we'll get a chance to
cross paths
sounds great never when I'm up that way
I'll definitely that let your people
know
thank you for more Dan Patrick show to
the audience channel 239 on DirecTV or
download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]